- Inge!
Bitte! Lass mich rein!
Wenn ich könnte, ich würde alles
rückgängig machen.
Die ganze Lügerei so viele Jahre lang.
Es ist einfach passiert.
Ich komme aus Duisburg, Inge.
Mein Vater war Arbeiter in der
Stahlindustrie …
und ich später auch.
Wir sind wie so viele in den 60er-Jahren
ins Ruhrgebiet gezogen.
Bis es dann keine Arbeit mehr gab.
Aber ich sah gut aus.
Mit den Frauen klappte es immer.
Und immer, wenn ich mit einer ausgegangen
war, bestand sie darauf, mich einzuladen …
den armen arbeitslosen Burschen.
Irgendwann … irgendwann habe ich das
dann genutzt … und verinnerlicht.
Meine Miete zahlte ich mit
Gebrauchtwagenhandel,
Fahrrädern, allem möglichen Kram.
Und die Frauen ermöglichten mir
ein schönes Leben.
Ein schönes Leben …
das bedeutet jetzt nur noch, mit dir
zusammen zu sein, Inge.
Und ich allein bin schuld, wenn
das ein Traum bleibt.